[Música]
es exponencial la cantidad de tiempo que
yo he gastado viendo gráficos
exponenciales en los últimos tres meses
y si ustedes son como yo probablemente
les ha ocurrido lo mismo y eso me trae a
mí dos retos importantes para esta
presentación de hoy el primero es que
los datos que voy a presentarles han ido
cambiando también de forma exponencial
en los últimos 15 días desde que roberto
me pidió que hiciera esta presentación
he hecho esta gráfica y estos datos y
esta presentación unas 15 veces porque
cada día el guión que debía presentar a
la diferente porque los datos crecen tan
rápido que todos los días son diferentes
y el segundo reto es procurar no
aburrirlos durante estos 15 minutos
porque si como yo han pasado viendo
gráficos tres meses deben estar hartos
de estar viendo gráficos desde hace tres
meses me tomé entonces el cuidado de
procurar hacer una presentación que sea
un poquito entretenida y no aburrirlos
con otro montón de gráficos más que han
visto tanto estos días para eso quiero
invitarlos a todos a todos a que se
vengan conmigo una máquina del tiempo
pero soy una máquina diferente es una
máquina que nos va a llevar al futuro
específicamente el futuro de costa rica
pero para ver el futuro de costa rica
vamos a dejar al pasado al pasado donde
inició la pandemia de ccoo y 19 porque
tenemos una circunstancia circunstancia
especial y es que la expansión de esta
pandemia es geográficamente lenta y va
avanzando desde china a europa y américa
y eso nos pone en una posición única en
el tiempo podemos ir atrás podemos ir a
ver lo que ocurrió en esos lugares y
esos lugares son el pasado y es lo que
podemos proyectar desde una perspectiva
comparativa de lo que podría ocurrir en
costa rica con diversos escenarios
entonces vengan conmigo este viaje el
tiempo
una salvedad es que los voy a presentar
a ustedes hoy no son proyecciones
matemáticas no son modelos de lo preciso
de lo que va a pasar en costa rica es
una invitación a ver lo que ha ocurrido
en otros lugares en el pasado y tratar
de pensar que ese podría ser nuestro
futuro hay expertos en costa rica que sí
están haciendo modelos matemáticos para
tratar de predecir y proyectar lo que ha
ocurrido pero mi intención hoy es que
podamos aprender del pasado de estos
países y traer ese aprendizaje a costa
rica
nuestra historia de tiempo arranca en
noviembre de 2019 en algún momento que
el paciente 0 se contagia de un nuevo
coronavirus no sabemos que ofrece
paciente ni la fecha exacta pero sí
sabemos que a partir del 6 de diciembre
empezaron a llegar a los hospitales de
buján en china- pacientes con síntomas
graves de tos fiebre y de dificultades
muy graves para respirar
ellos pensaron que era un brote de sars
la epidemia que azotó hacia en el año
2003 sin embargo ya para el 3 de enero
los científicos de china en wuhan habían
hecho el primer mapeo del genoma de un
nuevo coronavirus y determinaron que no
era el mismo virus sars
hasta esa fecha no había una evidencia
de que había contagio entre personas sin
embargo una misión de la oea es el 21 de
enero constató que había un contagio
sostenido entre personas y es en este
día 21 de enero que inicia nuestro viaje
hacia el pasado porque es el día a
partir del cual tengo datos datos duros
que he recolectado gracias a fuentes
oficiales y que les voy a presentar hoy
en forma de un viaje
tengamos en cuenta que en costa rica
este viaje arrancó el 6 de marzo cuando
se dio el primer caso confirmado y esto
es importante porque la fecha
epidemiológica en cada país es diferente
entonces en muchas de las gráficas que
voy a presentar estamos comparando los
países como avanzaron desde la fecha en
que en ese país arrancó el contagio o
desde la fecha en que en ese país
ocurrió la primera muerte
esta mañana cuando hice el último corte
de cómo estaba la situación en el mundo
teníamos casi un millón de casos
confirmados de contagios de covite del
virus que produce covite en el mundo y
lamentablemente casi 50.000 muertes de
esas dos muertes en costa rica que
realmente es asombroso que sean hasta el
momento tan pocas aunque sean
lamentables
un último detalle antes de empezar este
viaje vamos a agradecer a las fuentes de
datos el principal es la universidad
johns hopkins de donde estoy tomando la
base de datos cruda todos los datos del
mundo algunos datos del banco mundial y
estoy usando el software gap minder
ahora sí empecemos este viaje el pasado
nuestro viaje arranca en wuhan china en
algún momento de noviembre diciembre del
2019 como pueden ver el brote se expande
primero dentro de china y se mantiene
contenido en china aunque ya hay algunos
casos puntuales en el resto del mundo
pero no son brotes importantes podemos
ver que los días desde el 22 de enero
avanzan el contador que ustedes ven en
la cantidad de días que van pasando a
partir del 22 de enero y aproximadamente
hasta el día 30 y 40 se mantiene
contenida la expansión de la epidemia
dentro de china pero vean esos tres
puntos que empiezan a aparecer ya en el
día 41 se notaban claramente tres puntos
adicionales de contario corea del sur
irán e italia
y serían los tres puntos hacia donde la
epidemia empezaría a atacar el resto del
mundo ahora vean como la epidemia
empieza a expandirse principalmente en
europa y muy rápidamente
europa en su total ese se convierte en
el segundo lugar de impacto más grave de
la epidemia tanto en contagios como en
muertes y vean como ya a partir del día
59 60 es claro que el tercer gran foco
de contagio contagio es eeuu y al día de
hoy eeuu es el principal foco de
contagio del mundo si lo comparamos
tanto en cantidad de contagios aunque
aún todavía no en cantidad de muertos
porque la fecha epidemiológica eeuu va
un poco más retrasada
cómo se ha comportado esto en impacto y
lo quiero medir el impacto de vidas
humanas porque si viene la cantidad de
contagios es un dato relevante me
interesa más ver cómo se comparan los
países en personas fallecidas y 20
interesante si bien china lidera el
ranking al inicio en los primeros días
de contagio cuando estaba expandiendo
dentro de china es muy rápido que europa
tomar la delantera en lo más grave
muertos y en este caso que lo estoy
presentando por cada millón de
habitantes en italia en españa han
habido más de 200 muertos por millón de
habitantes imaginemos que si traemos eso
a costa rica con 5 millones de
habitantes estaríamos hablando de casi
mil muertos acumulados y el top de
países que tienen más impacto a nivel de
muertos es a europa se nos escuela por
ahí la posición número 7 irán y eeuu se
mantiene la 14 porque está un poco más
en el contrario pero vean como
es europa el que lidera en impacto y ahí
en el top no aparece en países de asia
de hecho china está en la posición 47
costa rica por cierto está la posición
en este momento con dos personas
fallecidas
ahora es importante ver esta cantidad de
personas que han fallecido no como un
solo dato acumulado sino verlo cómo
transcurrió cómo se destruyó en el
tiempo porque eso es importante para
como el sistema de salud de cada país va
a poder dar abasto atendiendo esas
personas contagiadas enfermas enfermas
graves o personas que van a llegar
lamentablemente a fallecer lo que se
pretende es aplanar la curva que exceso
rápidamente es que ese pico de contagio
no ocurra rápidamente en una o dos
semanas sino que se distribuye en el
tiempo y hacia el sistema de salud puede
dar abasto si las personas fallecen no
es porque el sistema de salud no estaba
disponible sino porque la enfermedad
realmente hizo que esa persona no
sobreviviera
y entonces quiero presentarle la curva
de un país de referencia que ha hecho
muy bien las cosas quiero presentarles a
corea del sur vamos a ver dos curvas
estas son curvas donde estoy viendo
en la parte vertical el total de
personas al día que se contagiaron y que
morían en korea
y abajo la línea de tiempo del día 1
hasta el día 70 que estamos actualmente
vean que tanto la curva la cantidad de
personas contagiadas como la cantidad de
personas que fallecía en korea era una
línea plana qué quiere decir que
diariamente se contagiaban pocas
personas y moría en pocas personas
en los primeros 30 días sin embargo bien
lo que pasa a partirles de a 30
rápidamente crece la curva y llega a su
pico máximo el caso de corea alrededor
del día 42 de la fecha epidemiológica y
a partir de ahí empieza a descender
también ahí sale la pico de personas que
han fallecido que se mantuvo muy bajo en
korea
ya a partir del día 55 la curva están en
su parte baja y se ha mantenido baja en
el tiempo
y sabemos que corea ha hecho muy bien
por muchas razones pero sobre todo a la
hora de compararlo con otros países cómo
podemos comparar con otros países vamos
a tomar dos cuidados
primero es muy diferente comparar un
país que tiene 60 millones de habitantes
mil millones de habitantes con países
que tienen 10 millones de habitantes
entonces vamos a ver algunos datos por
cada millón de habitantes y luego te
importante a la hora tener en cuenta la
comparación es que a partir de ahora no
voy a presentar datos de personas
contagiadas porque eso es un dato que se
mide muy diferente en cada país tanto
por razones técnicas por razones
políticas en algunos casos y en algunos
casos porque sencillamente no se está
midiendo la infraestructura la situación
del país hace que no haya datos y no se
estén midiendo la cantidad de personas
que se contagien pero la cantidad de
personas muertas es un dato y
lamentablemente más duro en todo el
mundo se mide igual no significa que se
esté midiendo perfectamente bien ya
sabemos que el país es donde ni siquiera
se está logrando llevar una contabilidad
de las personas fallecidas por kobe 19
pero por lo menos es un dato mucho más
duro
comparemos cómo han sido algunas curvas
de todo el mundo me tomé la libertad de
escoger adrede los países en este en
este orden primero de países de los que
no tengo datos esos no están presentes
aquí luego hay países que iniciaron muy
temprano en la curva de contagios son
los mejores porque tenemos muchos datos
para ver por ejemplo ahora estamos
viendo bélgica y españa holanda subiendo
rápidamente de forma muy pronunciada en
sus curvas de muertes diarias por cada
millón de habitantes este pico de españa
significa que en el día 30
aproximadamente había 20 personas por
cada millón de habitantes muriendo en
españa a causa de kobe 19 si traeremos
ese dato a costa rica estaremos hablando
de casi 1000 personas al día muriendo en
costa rica por kobe 19 en el pico de
nuestra curva vean como los países
europeos son los que tienen las curvas
más pronunciadas y los que han tenido
mayor cantidad de muertos por día y
luego otro relevante que quería
presentarles todas las líneas de abajo
pequeñitas que están viendo es asia
corea taiwán japón filipinas tailandia
se mantuvieron con curvas de personas
fallecidas muy bajas y también canadá
que tienen como en esos países yo me
atrevo a decir que fueron todos los
países incluyendo canadá los más
afectados por la epidemia de sars en el
año 2003
vamos a hacer zoom y vamos a ver ahora
es también más curvas pero para países
que estén más cerca de costa rica vamos
a ver latinoamerica y si una selección
de países igual con los mismos criterios
hay países de los que no tengo datos o
no son confiables por la situación
política como venezuela o como nicaragua
hay países de los que no hay datos
porque lleva muy poco tiempo y estos son
los países de los que hay más datos y de
los que para mí son preocupantes porque
lo que pasa en la región nos va a
afectar directamente a nosotros
dominicana tiene una cantidad importante
de contagios y de muertes esté
ocurriendo ecuador y lamentablemente
para panamá nuestro vecino del sur tiene
una gran cantidad de personas que están
falleciendo por día y las curvas de
estos países apenas están empezando a
crecer pero pongan atención a nuestro
vecino económico de turismo y comercial
más importante eeuu la curva de personas
en eeuu falleciendo millones de muertes
diarias por cada millón de habitantes
está creciendo verticalmente casi
exponencial y no sabemos cuándo va a
detenerse es muy preocupante que nuestro
vecino más importante esté en esa
situación
por último haciendo zoom más en detalle
quiero mostrarles a costa rica comparado
con españa y comparado con crear
en este caso si no estoy presentando a
datos de muertes por millón por que
dichosamente nuestra curva de muertes
este se ha mantenido plana no hemos
tenido ninguna otra persona fallecida
hasta el momento entonces voy a comparar
contagios que son datos que si tenemos
más información histórica vean que
durante los primeros 30 días tanto en
españa como en costa rica y en korea
teníamos pocos contagios por millón y es
a partir del día 30 en donde en que
tanto en corea como en españa empieza a
incrementar la cantidad de contagios en
el caso de corea logran mantenerla junto
a la curva de contagios y también
muertes y en lamentablemente en el caso
de españa esa curva se dispara de forma
casi exponencial
dichosamente llegando ya a bajar
y esta es una perspectiva de lo que
puede ser el futuro de costa rica-
viendo el pasado de estos dos países
estamos en un momento muy apropiado para
pensar cuál es el futuro que vamos a
construir
con dosis te suena muy dos ventajas muy
importantes la primera es que el futuro
de costa rica aún no está escrito lo
estamos escribiendo y la segunda es que
estamos a tiempo viendo el pasado de lo
que ocurrió en estos países trayendo la
perspectiva a costa rica y teniendo la
oportunidad de tomar medidas para
mitigar para contener esta esta
expansión de la que está la epidemia
quiero terminar invitándolos a tener
todas las medidas del ministerio de
salud ya compartirles este sitio web
cobit punto tick punto cr donde están
publicados todos estos gráficos que
acabo de presentarles de forma fácil no
se necesita ser informático no necesita
conocimiento de computación ustedes
entren va a poder seleccionar sus países
de interés y van a poder ver estas
mismas curvas y gráficos pero para todo
el mundo o sus países de interés quedo
atento a sus preguntas y consultas
muchas gracias
[Música]